bonjour Le 7 8 l'actu sur TVfil on se 15
novembre débute l'essentiel de
l'information locale et voici les
principaux titres que nous allons à
développer à plaisir les fidèles de
l'église Saint-Pierre vont découvrir un
site totalement rénové l'inauguration
aura lieu samedi en présence de l'évêque
et Monseigneur homonyme
les contes de l'Université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin dans le rouge
l'établissement au bord de la cessation
de paiement le syndicat U9 vient de
tenir une réunion d'informations pour
les étudiants hier soir la collecte
nationale du Secours Catholique s'ouvre
une opération annuelle qui met à
l'accent cette année sur l'emploi des
personnes en situation précaire François
Paget est délégué départemental du
Secours catholique dans les Yvelines
sera sur ce plateau dans quelques
instants l'image du jour c'est un arbre
cet arbre premier arbre symbole du
chantier de l'ESTACA l'école d'ingénieur
qui a choisi de s'implanter à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux vous allez le
voir en images dans un instant voilà
ensuite à quoi ressemblera j'espère
qu'on va voir les images que vous
puissiez suivre l'inauguration de
l'ESTACA ce bâtiment qui fera 10 000 m²
qui permettra à la rentrée 2015
d'accueillir dans un premier temps 1100
étudiants le voilà donc cet arbre qui
est symbole de ce chantier
l'établissement qui ensuite été présenté
cette école l'ESTACA forme aux quatre
filières du transport aéronautique
automobile spatial et ferroviaire
l'école qui quitte ses loc aux de
Levallois-Perret pour venir à 50 ans en
Yvelines un choix logique selon la
directrice générale Pascal ribbon que
l'on devrait à présent pouvoir écouter
on a fait le choix de s'installer sur ce
territoire à la fois parce qu'on y avait
beaucoup de partenaires des partenaires
industriels beaucoup de centres de R&D
dans le domaine des transports
automobiles bien sûr aéronautique des
sociétés d'ingénierie et puis on y avait
aussi des partenaires académiques de
longue date je pense à en particulier à
l'université de Versailles 51 en
Yvelines et
c'est un territoire sur lequel aussi on
a rencontré un fort dynamisme et un vrai
soutien de la part des collectivités
territoriales c'était une volonté
stratégique de la part du conseil
d'administration de l'estacade de
s'implanter sur le territoire de
l'opération d'intérêt national
Paris-Saclay parce que voilà c'est une
de ces la thématique de ce du
développement de ce grand campus
correspond tout à fait à notre à la fois
notre positionnement et à notre volonté
de développement et on avait aussi là
encore un certain nombre de partenaires
dans ce dans ce dans ce projet
présentation de cette grande école qui
s'est déroulée donc ce vendredi matin
l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et mal en
point son président Jean-Luc Veyssière
envoyé à l'ensemble du personnel un
courrier pour expliquer qu'il manquait 4
millions d'euros à l'université sur les
19 nécessaires pour boucler le budget
jusqu'au 31 décembre l'État aurait bien
consenti une rallonge en demandant en
échange la suspension immédiate par
l'Université du règlement de ses
factures cela s'appelle une cessation de
paiement en cause des embauches trop
nombreuses des investissements
immobiliers qui coûtent très cher le
syndicat UNEF a tenu ce jeudi soir à une
réunion à destination des étudiants pour
les informer et tenter de proposer des
solutions tout en portant un regard
assez critique sur les choix de la
direction ces dernières années
c'est difficile elle a des conséquences
directes sur les conditions d'études des
étudiants puisque on peut faire
plusieurs constats à l'heure actuelle
c'est la dégradation de nos conditions
d'études notamment il y a plusieurs
options dans certaines filières qui ont
été supprimées des heures de cours
également qui ont été supprimées on
parle également de la suppression d'une
filière entière la filière de STAPS donc
concrètement c'est difficile à des
conséquences directes sur nos conditions
d'études et sur la réussite des
étudiants quoi le but de cette assemblée
générale c'est d'abord d'avoir un débat
entre étudiant sur comment les étudiants
vivent enfin quel est leur ressenti sur
leurs conditions d'études etc récolter
éventuellement des témoignages
supplémentaires puisque l'UNEF ne veut
pas être partout donc si on reste pas en
contact avec les étudiants on peut pas
avoir une évaluation claire de la
situation samedi 16 novembre sera
officiellement inaugurée l'église
Saint-Pierre de plaisir c'est en réalité
la fin d'un chantier de rénovation
débuté il y a 19 mois des plaisirs ont
déjà pu découvrir l'édifice en
avant-première Catherine zelato et
Evanston berger était présent
Ricardo Giordano a le sourire et les
yeux rivés vers la voûte de l'église
Saint-Pierre de plaisir l'architecte
scrute chaque détail il a suivi la
rénovation de cet édifice du 13e siècle
depuis le début du chantier il y a 19
mois il se souvient de sa première
visite nous avons trouvé un édifice
sombre qui était très bouleversé par son
histoire récente
qui était notamment celle d'un problème
structurel très important de ces parties
les plus hautes et les plus lourdes
notamment son clocher et toutes les
structures dont ils se trouvaient sous
ce clocher et qui faisait qu'il était
étayé donc elle était complètement
incombrée par les étés des étaient posés
depuis une vingtaine d'années une partie
de l'église était fermée au public un
hôtel provisoire posé sur un podium si
on voulait la rendre à son public il
fallait bien que ce soit tout d'abord
consolidé dans ces parties les plus
lourdes et puis ensuite on a consolidé
toutes les maçonneries notamment qui
avait été affaiblie par ces problèmes
structuro et
travailler sur ensuite un peu plus
finement si vous voulez sur la sur la
restauration des décors du mobilier
intérieur qui avait complètement disparu
et parmi ce mobilier un coffre caché
dans la sacristie mais il était vide les
architectes ont aussi été attirés par la
qualité polychromique je suis absolument
étonné de ce qu'ils sont arrivés à faire
parce que c'est formidable d'arriver à
le travail qu'il y a derrière tout cela
le travail historique il y a tout ça on
retrouve quand même l'âme de l'église
une âme dont peut témoigner Joël rénaux
l'ancien maire dans cette église il a
été baptisé il a fait ses communions je
crois que l'émotion à ma pas quitté
depuis que les travaux ont commencé j'ai
du mal à chaque fois que je viens de
retenir ne serait-ce que des larmes
pourquoi pas le dire ah oui c'est vrai
la rénovation a coûté 5,5 millions
d'euros financés en grande partie par la
ville avec des soutiens du conseil
général régional et des paroissiens
eux-mêmes nous avons eu plus de 313
donateurs donc c'est quand même je
dirais un engouement général on a pu
constater que c'était une attente une
attente aujourd'hui terminée des
journées portes ouvertes ont lieu ce
dimanche après-midi un concert est
organisé samedi 23 novembre et la façade
sera illuminée jusqu'au 15 janvier et je
reçois à présent pour continuer cette
édition François page et bonjour bonjour
vous êtes le délégué départemental du
Secours Catholique des Yvelines 16 17
novembre collectes nationales annuel
c'est un moment important toutes les
actions que vous allez mener vont
dépendre un petit peu des recettes de
l'argent que vous allez réussir à
collecter pendant cette période
exactement une grosse partie de nos
recettes vient en fin d'année comme
beaucoup d'ailleurs dans le monde
associatif qui dépend de dons des privés
mais effectivement c'est une grosse
période pour nous alors comme on va se
dérouler cette collecte sur le terrain
tout au long du week-end ah très bien
très bien elle va très bien on a déjà
commencé oui oui en fait donc le Secours
catholique dans les Yvelines c'est 70
équipes différentes donc chacune va
organiser finalement sa collecte à sa
manière mais il y aura des activités
très différentes que ce parfois des
distributions d'enveloppes dans les
gares que ce soit à la sortie des
eucharisties ou alors des présences sur
le marché ou du kettage sur la voie
publique avec des troncs enfin des
activités très variées l'essentiel pour
nous c'est de faire un événement à la
fois de collecte financière de présence
finalement d'être vu et puis aussi un
moment de convivialité pour permettre à
la fois nos bénévoles et nous accueillir
les salariés tous ensemble d'être sur le
terrain en mission pendant quelques
jours et donc c'est aussi un moment où
finalement on est ensemble ces actions
ensuite que vous allez pouvoir mener
quelles sont-elles quelles sont les
actions principales menées
principales action finalement que l'on
mène c'est de permettre des accueils de
convivialité aux personnes en difficulté
la précarité se développe en France
94% des personnes que nous recevons sont
sous le seuil de pauvreté donc on est
bien avec les tranches de population qui
sont en grande difficulté leur permettre
d'avoir un café d'avoir un lieu place
pour pouvoir avoir un moment de
convivialité discuter être reçu être
accueilli et puis être soutenu qui
financièrement qui avec une aide
alimentaire ou investir mais la l'action
finalement la plus symbolique c'est le
lieu d'accueil le lutte convivialité la
collecte chaque année permet de récolter
combien d'argent alors beaucoup d'argent
au niveau national nous sur les Yvelines
on va récolter en fait un ensemble de
dons autour de 3 millions d'euros quel
que soit les formes de dons sur le
département sur le département et
l'essentiel de cet argent n'est pas
dépensé sur le département l'essentiel
va être reversé à la caisse commune pour
soutenir des départements qui sont plus
en difficulté même si les Yvelines sont
un département riches de France il y a
des pauvreté donc nous avons besoin de
dépenser aussi un peu d'argent ici mais
l'essentiel va être reversé ensuite
cibler en fonction des besoins sur
l'ensemble du territoire français du
territoire français et même de la
solidarité internationale 60% des dons
qui sont collectés dans les Yvelines
vont repartir à la caisse commune pour
aider qu'il a Seine-Saint-Denis qu'il a
Guyane ou à des actions à
l'international la crise économique la
difficulté financières les biens sont
bien présentes c'est une réalité
aujourd'hui pour bon nombre d'entre nous
nous avons voulu savoir si la crise
aujourd'hui vous empêchez de donner aux
associations si vous donniez moins vos
réponses
bah non ça évidemment une influence à la
mesure où on a de moins en moins
liquidité et de moins en moins d'argent
de plus en plus d'impôts je pense pas
parce que quand il se passe des choses
comme motif le typhon même si on peut
rien faire à notre niveau ici bah le
seul moyen c'est de l'envoyer de
l'argent pour qu'il puisse manger et
boire on se sent impliqué donc crise ou
pas crise je pense que oui
malheureusement on n'a pas forcément les
sous même si on sait que c'est on a des
réductions d'impôts c'est vrai que ça
fait quand même des sous en moins
notamment pour les enfants pour Noël
aussi donc voilà on pense
malheureusement on est obligé de penser
un petit peu à soi avant les autres et
c'est bien dommage bien sûr bien sûr
c'est évident
parce que nous-mêmes on fait attention
aux achats que l'on fait parce que c'est
vrai qu'on est écrasé de plus en plus
non je donne toujours
à toutes les associations très peu mais
je donne c'est la crise pour les autres
aussi
ça vous inquiète cette année avec les
difficultés financières toutes ces
hausses aussi d'impôts que subissent
tous les ménages est-ce que les dons
seront moins nombreux alors c'est un
nous verrons après coup mais ce que l'on
voit en tout cas c'est que l'envie de
soutenir et l'envie d'aider les autres
restent très présente dans la population
française effectivement comme on dit
plusieurs de vos interlocuteurs la crise
est là et les situations compliquées
financièrement des solidarités
familiales les anciens qui doivent aider
les plus jeunes ça c'est vrai c'est réel
mais nous voyons quand même que les dons
continuent alors effectivement peut-être
on verra les fruits au global mais en
tout cas des fruits peut-être parfois
plus faibles pour chaque don mais le
nombre de donateurs pour l'instant n'a
pas l'air de fléchir l'action que nous
faisons au quotidien c'est notre
meilleur manière d'être présent et
d'être connu et du coup effectivement
d'espérer puisque on saura les chiffres
qu'après le 31 décembre mais
effectivement d'espérer que cette baisse
sera le plus faible possible en marge de
cette collecte le Secours Catholique qui
s'interroge chaque année sur les
difficulté rencontrée par les personnes
que vous accompagnez Satani plus
particulièrement sur le lien à l'emploi
de ces personnes accompagnées vous
inviter les pouvoirs publics à se
mobiliser contre la montée de la
précarité qu'elle est un petit peu les
l'état des lieux la situation
actuellement pour les personnes que vous
suivez au quotidien la grosse majorité
des personnes un quasiment 80% de des
personnes que nous recevons sont en
recherche d'emploi ne sont pas dans le
dans l'emploi et même ces petits 20% qui
sont dans l'emploi un tiers encore va
être en temps partiel ça veut dire que
vraiment l'essentiel des personnes que
nous rencontrez que nous rencontrons ne
sont pas en situation d'emploi à temps
plein de manière à pouvoir vivre de leur
de leur emploi donc c'est vrai que c'est
une situation qui est très préoccupante
pour nous avec une montée de couple avec
enfants dans les accueils et une
difficulté finalement à constater que la
situation par rapport à l'emploi se
sclérose s'installe en fait la
proportion de personnes qui sont au
chômage depuis moins de 6 mois c'est
réduit
elle était de 40% il y a 10 ans
aujourd'hui plus que 30%, ça veut dire
que le chômage de longue durée
indemnisé ou pas mais le chômage de
longue durée s'installe et finalement il
y a une forme de sclérose et cela touche
tout le monde toutes les tranches cela
touche tout le monde toutes les tranches
d'âge le chômage des jeunes augmente
parce que ce chiffre national c'est 77%
des jeunes chômeurs que vous accueillez
ne sont pas indemnisés oui oui c'est
c'est le réel c'est l'indemnisation
n'est pas égale forcément à avoir
travaillé avant l'indemnisation elle
peut être ou la non indemnisation peut
être aussi le fruit d'accident du
travail ou de difficultés médicales elle
peut être a pour une femme après sa
période d'avoir élevé des enfants
l'envie de revenir vers le travail et ne
pas avoir accès donc il y a
effectivement de nombreuses causes à la
non indemnisation des personnes mais
effectivement cette dimension alors
c'est vrai que nous nous recevons des
personnes qui sont très pauvre ou très
éloigné de l'emploi c'est très différent
d'une personne qui est un cadre qui se
trouve dans une période de sa vie en
difficulté dans le corps il est il est
pas très loin de l'emploi les personnes
qui sont en situation d'être
désocialisée ou d'être au fur et à
mesure des années vous avez constaté une
difficulté accrue justement ces
personnes n'arrivent pas se remettre
dans le circuit de l'eau elles ont envie
et pourtant elles n'y arrivent pas et en
fait ce que nous constatons c'est qu'il
y a à retrouver la confiance en soi
retrouver j'ai de la valeur je peux
contribuer pour que du coup c'est aussi
le travail que vous menez au quotidien
un dernier mot concernant les
Philippines les dons de ce week-end vont
servir justement à aider les victimes du
typhon alors une partie des dons servira
pour aider les victimes du typhon oui
tout à fait les équipes de Caritas le
Philippines sont déjà sur le terrain
puisqu'elles sont elles sont là et donc
le Secours Catholique faisant partie du
réseau Caritas et déjà actif depuis le
début sur le terrain merci d'être venu
sur ce plateau nous parler de votre
action et de cette collecte n'oubliez
pas la collecte tout au long du week-end
du Secours Catholique merci cette
semaine encore été marquée par une forte
contestation sociale les policiers
étaient dans la rue mercredi avec pour
motordre poulet mais papillon des
yvelinois étaient dans le cortège à des
manifestants qui a défilé devant
l'Assemblée nationale pour dénoncer le
budget 2014 en baisse depuis quatre ans
et le manque de moyens et le protestait
également contre la plateforme de l'IGPN
qui va permettre à des citoyens de
dénoncer des comportements de policiers
nous sommes les premiers fonctionnaires
d'État à subir de plein fouet cette
baisse de rémunération alors que tous
les élus nous disent partout qu'on est
les remparts de la République et
notamment les derniers remparts de la
République ce sont des restrictions
budgétaires qui font qu'aujourd'hui dans
les services on a des problèmes pour
renouveler le parc automobile
ou tout simplement pour acheter des
ramettes de papier à la fin de l'année
ce qui est absolument dramatique je dis
chez les enseignants aussi étaient en
grève une grève contre les nouveaux
rythmes scolaires qui doivent
s'appliquer à la rentrée prochaine pour
l'ensemble des établissements
mobilisations suivies et relayées aussi
par l'opposition
UMP dans les Yvelines Jean-Michel
fourgousse merdéencourt Valérie Pécresse
conseillère régional Île-de-France mène
la fronde le maire d'Élancourt qui
annonce par ailleurs qu'il n'appliquera
pas quoi qu'il advienne la réforme dans
sa ville eux aussi sont en colère ce
sont les usagers des centres équestres
la TVA doit passer prochainement de 7 à
20% une obligation européenne la France
a déjà été condamnée par la Cour de
justice de l'Union seulement depuis
l'annonce de cette hausse de TVA elle a
mobilisation ne cesse de prendre de
l'ampleur Yolaine Torres
Catherine gère le haras de Gazeran
depuis 26 ans sur les cinq salariés
qu'elle emploi elle envisage peut-être
de supprimer un poste à cause de la
future taxe moi je vais perdre des
clients voilà qui pourront pas suivre
voilà et puis et ben après de voir
licencier parce que si on a moins de
chiffre d'affaires moins de rentrer on
pourra pas garder toute personne le GHM
dont je fais partie estimé qu'il y
aurait à peu près 6000 postes en France
qui vont être supprimés à cause de cette
augmentation de TVA les petites
structures qui étaient déjà affaiblies
un petit peu avec la crise risque de pas
s'en remettre ah oui ça c'est certain
les centres équestres ont déjà connus
des remous concernant leur TVA mais
celle annoncé pour l'année prochaine et
de loin la plus menaçante pour eux selon
la Fédération Nationale du cheval 2000
entreprises seraient en péril
en 2004 la filière équestre bénéficier
d'une TVA réduite à
5,5%. à l'époque l'objectif était de
promouvoir l'équitation il y a deux ans
elle était passée à 7% l'année dernière
une activité était déjà passée à
19,6%, celle du commerce des chevaux
sport et loisirs là aussi sous la
pression l'Union européenne à noter que
le commerce des chevaux d'élevage et de
consommation lui restent taxé à hauteur
de
7%. l'année prochaine ce seront toutes
les activités du centre équestre qui
passeront à 19,6%. menacé d'une saisine
de la Cour de justice de l'Union
européenne pour manquement sûrement et
d'une amende de plusieurs dizaines de
millions d'euros le gouvernement veut se
mettre en conformité rapidement un coup
dur pour le département des Yvelines
avec 21 licenciés et plus de 200 centres
il est le deuxième département et
Castres de France derrière le Nord
à Rambouillet Déborah ne craint pas la
fermeture de son entreprise qu'elle
estime viable pour autant elle le
comprend pas cette hausse de la TVA dans
l'équitation contrairement aux autres
sports les subventions sont quasi
inexistantes ce sont surtout des
établissements professionnels du coup il
est parfois difficile pour les gérants
de se faire une marge réelle les frais
de fonctionnement sont très lourds
les structures coûtent cher
le les chevaux de montent beaucoup
d'entretiens ils mangent enfin il
demande à ce qu'on s'occupe d'eux pas
cinq jours sur 7 et pas 35 heures comme
une entreprise qui ferme ses portes ou
un gymnase donc voilà nous c'est 7 jours
sur 7 ils sont malades c'est 24 heures
sur 24 et bah tout ça ça se paye quoi ça
un coup d'après le groupement épique
national sur les 250 000 chevaux que
compte les centres d'équitation 80000
seraient envoyés à l'abattoir pour se
faire entendre les professionnels se
mobilisent dans le département ils ont
organisé une opération escargot ce jeudi
et leur groupe FaceBook crée il y a
quelques jours compte déjà plus de 700
abonnés
premier département équestre de France
les Yvelines seront fortement impactés
le Conseil général se dit solidaire des
manifestants qui seront d'ailleurs
présents à Paris le 19 novembre en
présence de convoi devenu de toute la
France et je vous renvoie à notre site
Internet pour écouter en replay
l'intervention de Christine Boutin elle
était à l'invité hier du journal elle
est en charge pour le Conseil Général de
la mission cheval dans le département
l'Agence Locale de l'énergie et du
climat à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines Lens
demain samedi l'opération famille a
énergie positive c'est en fait un défi
lancé aux particuliers afin de réduire
leurs dépenses énergétiques pour en
parler à Laurence mon bonjour bienvenue
sur ce plateau chargé de communication
et de projet pédagogique pour l'ALEC
comment va se dérouler cette opération
ça va durer plusieurs mois alors ça dure
plusieurs mois voilà donc le défi
commence officiellement le 1er décembre
jusque fin avril
donc sur cinq mois
voilà
propriétaire ou locataire
d'énergie et l'objectif
c'est 8 % d'économies d'énergie par
rapport à la à l'année précédente donc
sur la consommation des appareils
électroménagers à la maison des
équipements électriques de la
consommation d'eau chaude et également
le chauffage donc vous les laissez pas
tout seul non plus ils sont accompagnés
il y a un capitaine d'équipe qui a été
formé par des professionnels
donc un gars qui tend d’équipe qui est
formé et également les conseillers infos
énergie de l'Agence Locale de l'énergie
seront là pour conseiller pour répondre
aux questions et puis ils seront aidés
enfin les familles seront aussi aidés de
petits équipements de mesure pour voir
effectivement où sont les consommations
ça veut dire que les familles vont
devoir se priver pour gagner à tout prix
le concours ou une des conditions c'est
ça
voilà l'objectif c'est vraiment sans
négliger le confort également sans
investissement uniquement par des
éco-gestes et c'est faisable c'est
atteignable ce seuil de 8% d'économies
par rapport à la des précédentes c'est
tout à fait faisable les ce défi existe
en fait en France depuis 5 ans sur les
cinq éditions précédentes plus de 80%
des équipes réussissent l'objectif donc
on est vraiment sur un fort taux de
réussite et alors ensuite est-ce que
c'est famille font attention au
quotidien parce que c'est bien de
participer à un concours c'est bien de
leur emporter mais après est-ce que
c'est les bons gestes sont acquis
d'après les études qui sont menées
effectivement les gestes qui sont faits
lors du Défi pendant 5 mois ont le temps
d'être acquis et de perdurer dans le
temps et souvent ce qui se passe c'est
que du coup on rajoute d'autres
éco-gestes spontanément les familles
rajoutent d'autres éco-gestes
les 8% sont atteignables si vous nous
suivez vous ne participez peut-être pas
au concours mais vous pouvez en faisant
attention au quotidien à faire attention
à vos factures il y a un seuil maximal
pour le nombre d'inscription du nombre
de familles c'est encore participer tout
à fait c'est tout faire les inscriptions
sont ouvertes jusqu'à la fin du mois
donc faut pas hésiter surtout surtout à
s'inscrire il y aura un lancement tout
de même officiel ça va se dérouler ce
week-end à la Maison de l'Environnement
et des sciences et du développement
durable à Manille et un mot en cours de
l'après-midi vers 16h comment ça va se
dérouler c'est pour présenter les
familles les faire se rencontrer et
c'est ouvert à tout le monde voilà tout
à fait l'objectif c'est de répondre aux
questions des des familles qui auraient
encore des questions par rapport à des
filles puisque l'information passe
depuis quelques temps maintenant mais
voilà on n'est jamais trop il y a jamais
trop d'informations qui passent sur le
sujet et donc de pouvoir répondre aux
questions de pouvoir aussi répondre aux
questions des personnes existantes parce
que ça peut faire peur or c'est c'est un
jeu le principe c'est vraiment faire des
économies en jouant dans un esprit
convivial et d'échanges il y aura des
ateliers demain aussi voilà tout à fait
apprendre les bons gestes est-ce que
justement pour conclure avec les
périodes un petit peu difficiles on en
parlait encore tout à l'heure est-ce que
les gens font attention à leur
consommation ils viennent vous demander
des conseils aussi pour l'hiver de plus
en plus
on a des questions sur plus des travaux
du bâtiment comme l'isolation ou le
changement de mode de chauffage ou de
vitrage etc mais il y a aussi des
questions sur les éco-gestes alors
souvent on a l'impression que on fait
déjà des choses mais il y a encore
d'autres choses à faire et puis il y a
enfin il y a plein de éco-gestes qu'on
connaît pas donc c'est
l'opportunité de les connaître
ce sera lancé présenté demain à la
Maison de l'Environnement à 50 ans en
Yvelines vous pouvez vous inscrire
auprès de l'ALEC elle les renseignements
qui se sont affichés sur votre écran
vous pouvez prendre contact pour
participer à cette opération avec ce
défi réduire de 8% votre consommation
d'énergie par rapport à l'hiver dernier
merci à vous merci on va terminer cette
édition avec les images du nouveau film
de Jamel Debbouze la marche le trappiste
sera présent à Saint-Quentin à l'UGC à
Montigny pour présenter ce film ce sera
ce week-end la marche des beurre une
marche des beurre entre Paris et
Marseille voici 30 ans et qui sert de
support historique à ce film
-moi là qu'est-ce qu'il y a
le monde est ainsi
l'histoire est ainsi
la justice n'est pas un acquis elle est
le fruit de la révolte lève-toi
lève-toi et bats-toi
on se parle justement ne te tais pas
ne doute pas
avance
sois la promesse d'un futur plus juste
et que nos pas hier hésitants
accompagné aujourd'hui un destin
en marche
avant première donc de ce film la marge
prévue dimanche avec l'équipe du film
des 16h30 le journal revient à lundi
pour un nouveau point complet sur
l'actualité local très bon week-end sur
notre antenne